And the new world order tentacles go deep,
deep,
deep.
Like a Dr Dre on a Tuesday.
I was going off yesterday.
I was saying how Joey Diaz will get mad about catch up and have you ever heard
him talking about rats fucking hate red.
I don't know how the fuck people delete that shit.
I don't know how people could be ranch.
I like when I go to a place and I say you,
oh you have wings and they say clubs or ranch.
I get up and leave even if I don't get the wings.
Because if you're going to serve wings or ranch,
I don't want to do business with you.
Wings must be done with Gucci.
Gucci?
Yeah.
Like the way of they invented in Buffalo,
New York and we got to do what would original.
You're going to show up with that rest that smells like somebody that she was
still same way.
Ranch is starting to replace ketchup.
Yeah.
That's good.
If you're fucking hillbilly and you want the taste the ass in your mouth,
I'll fucking,
I hate that fucking race shit.
Don't pull it close to me.
Don't put it around me and see the blue cheese.
We'll wings and go fuck him up.
That's the next year.
All right,
please.
He'll give you his album.
You know that Frank's long and gives that albums.
He plays right here at fucking Malibu.
The Malibu in once a month.
He's got the blue.
You got to go as a goof on time.
All the Italian show up,
they kiss him.
What do you think his relationship was like with his brother?
What do you think it would be?
It must be crazy.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Locked the door behind you and want to invest in a cheeseburger chain and you're
going to be the head singer.
A great number of which are marijuana.
One in six,
one in jail are there from about one in six people,
a victimless crime with people in prison in six people in prison.
Just welcome me about what it,
it's a business.
What the fuck do you want?
Nobody knows prison is a business,
so all this shit,
you guys talked about them checking the doors.
The feds,
I've never seen it.
I go get weed every day.
Stop scaring these fucking white kids and getting them talking.
This is nonsense.
But what are we getting that I know it's illegal.
I know it should be legal and I know that the John Lennon is gonna make a
comeback,
but for today,
for today,
2000 books that tonight.
Yeah,
that's important.
It's not together with Fallon and the presence hip,
but what?
I don't give a fuck dawg.
I'm smoking.
Look,
look here.
Here's what I think about your whole drug thing.
Looks like the same thing I've rubbed my balls with for the last 32 years with
the sativas and the bullshit.
Just get high go.
You'll be breakthrough.
Much drama to the gift that God gave us.
Again,
there's,
there's been,
um,
you know,
a lot of people that are moving towards a minimalist house is really small
houses and you know,
the idea is that like,
really why do we have to have this giant fucking footprint of House that we live
in Rhode Island because you're getting paid,
bitch,
if I want to live in a fucking cell,
I'm living a fucking sound like a monkey.
I'm going to live on a foldable bed like I'm a shaded Bollix.
If you're getting paid,
you live in the fucking house.
I'm going to live in a Mike Rowe fucking house with a little kitchen.
The pope,
like I got a black guy bagging me in a Badass.
I don't leave that a micro house.
What do you fucking people talking about?
I just snapped out of his dog.
You can't take me into those deep waters like
Rika fucking kills a brother right now.
The fuck are used people,
Mike Micro houses in the fucking desert.
You play it out to the world is like a doctor.
I want to live in one of their streams.
Brian's down.
Joey's not.
I think we have a real clear line.
I'm here with the new world champion
Jon Bones Jones.
I feel bad for that.
Resilient.
You been at work on a 10th planet.
Shit,
they're going to get bored and if he's going to fucking brightness guys
dropping knowledge like a mother enemy.
He was a black lab.
There's so many stories like that,
right?
If a guy going nuts over a check,
hey,
in the sixth grade by,
that's why we got to live in back over New Yorker reasons.
Boosie though that bus,
he sent me for a loop with the sixth grade.
I couldn't even think I had quit karate.
I just stopped talking to my friends,
just banging out,
just bagging,
dry hump and I started drying up and I was a little funnel teddies and then once
I got,
she told me she wouldn't give him.
She told me she wouldn't give me a piece of bushy two a day,
first day after school.
I couldn't wait till the last day of fucking sixth grade,
but my grades were so low at all.
That was on my mind was banging this chick for three months and it finally I had
to go to summer school.
Summer School,
three days.
They leave you back.
I fucking even cut summer school.
Fuck it.
This pussy served.
By that time she was giving me the push.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I was just looking at it and looking at what the fuck was going on.
I was just doing little licks at it.
I was hoping it would meet me.
And then when I caught caught playing hooky with that girl that the sixth grade,
cause we used to go to school and then take off in the afternoons.
I go one day my mother's home,
they fucking call.
So me and this girl lived caddy house.
Like there was a house behind mine next to her so I could just jump the fence
and on the corner of being the house,
the windows were open and she's out there yelling and screaming.
I had the mother's next door and she's like,
Ooh Da.
That's what happens.
Ever since.
Your daughter's going to hang on to hope my son
and they fuck all afternoon.
How to sub Dick,
who was killing my mother.
It was killing her.
It was killing the so much.
Even brought my uncle from California one day because they couldn't figure out
what I was doing in the room.
So my uncle put a ladder in the back of the house.
I ain't tried to climb up and shit.
Meanwhile I'm drawing a blank.
I'm rocking her fucking world.
That ladder fell.
He's done the audio meal.
I ate his meal,
his legs fucking Bro.
Like we're fixing pain.
Like I busted them write out like a week later,
my mother is like,
we're going to get you my brother.
We're going to get you a little money to your brother because you did something.
My mother blamed that on me.
Fucking hysterical.
Do you understand me?
What I went through with this New Yorker reason ago.
Now she's on Facebook and she won't talk to me.
I messaged the twice I even fucking farm.
Duh.
You know what I'm saying?
Farmville.
Then he started going off and he's screaming at me on the phone after he at me
for leaving a message.
I fucked up and left a voicemail message on his machine.
If you leave a message as machine,
he'll go crazy and call you up and mother fuck you.
[inaudible] so if you call his voicemail,
oh
message.
I told them,
listen,
I have dressed
to school.
Good.
Okay.
Have a great day.
Eddie Bravo in the falcon line.
Remember that
Eddie got mad at the Joey Diaz ones cause Joey Diaz is the master of the one
liner.
Yeah.
You know,
and Eddie had this,
uh,
you know,
any like changed his look over the years and became much more focused on his
music,
became much more rock and roll style.
And he had this big bracelet on.
It was nowhere leather bracelet.
Yeah.
And you know,
they're stylish people like wearing them whatever.
But uh,
Joey Diaz is like,
what are you waiting for a fucking song,
Alana.
I remember I laughed so hard.
He's fucking that transvestite joke.
One of the greatest jokes anybody's ever sold on stage.
He goes,
I like transvestites.
They Cook,
they clean,
they couldn't beat on him.
Every once in a while the cops come who they're going to believe me at some dude
with a wig and a black guy.
There's no support groups for these people.
Is the cops calm?
Who are they going to believe?
We sword booed a wig and a black guy
that's just,
you know,
that's this poetry man.
To me,
that's poetry to checks his email.
The guy is that guy in the,
what was that movie?
Leguizamo.
Son of Sam.
Yeah,
the BGS had Dan.
Can I tell you Joey sitting down in the last,
I dunno,
five minutes.
You've already done what my favorite Joey Diaz move is,
is it turns into a game shout we're,
he'll go,
you know that movie?
Uh,
you know the movie.
It's like reverse 20 quests that help joeys Stonehenge.
You know what?
I kidnapped that guy.
I kidnap them.
I did that.
I got four years.
I got all fucking easy.
They should have called me in there for 10 fucking years,
but people don't really,
how much time did you actually do?
18 months.
16 months.
Your freedom gets lost,
which sucks,
but it's the people at home.
It's not you or whatever.
I can do whatever the fuck it,
bro.
My jeans are from Cuba.
Motherfuckers.
Tell me about,
I smoked the weed.
Castro smoked before he went to the mountains to take over.
What's a typical day live in like a doctor who liked it.
I became a standup comic.
I learned how to do standup killing prisoners on Thursday nights.
They used to have movie night.
I didn't even know that.
They used to have movie that on Thursday night.
So the projector would always fuck up like Ustream.
I would always go,
what the fuck is wrong with them projecting?
No.
Everybody would say Cuba.
Get up there and talk and I would make fun of the black guys.
But what would it be?
What would you say?
You know,
we make fun of the kitchen the first day in prison.
It may be a baker,
you know,
you don't,
you don't tell people what you want.
It's like Cuba.
Like yeah,
the outside,
I was a mechanic really?
Well and here you are,
a baker going to say,
here's a book,
learn how to make bagels.
I may be sending them.
Rose dog almost blew up the kitchen,
right?
These mother fuckers are big.
So that afternoon they fired me,
has a baker and they made me a fucking dishwasher right now,
whenever they had shitty meals,
the guys I knew when they would go through the line and I would yell,
don't do,
but there's more drugs on the inside.
There was,
it wasn't any oxide.
And to boot.
This was a minimum security camp.
We had contact visits.
When you have a contact visit,
there's parties every night.
But that's the first time I did it.
No,
I was like,
the second time I did it,
no one was there and he couldn't do a needle.
So the Mexican is took a Mexican thing,
a heroin melted it.
I had to put like a funnel in mind.
Those made out of paper and they drifted in my nose and I got mad like candle
wick,
Bro,
what the fuck is this?
They're like,
that's heroin man.
Be Cool.
I was like this for like a day.
And then the white dudes,
Michael's gimmie speed and they would play basketball all fucking night.
I'll be out there of hell's angels
and there'd be out there with them.
Half of them every week.
It was a new adventure.
So on Thursday nights they would say,
Cuba,
fuck the movie.
Just go up there and talk about the kitchen.
And they were all,
all the yarns would yell,
don't do it.
I went in there every Thursday I get onstage and then one day a guy in the
library,
it was like a nerdy dude,
the guy that ran the library and I was friends with him.
We did acid and the funny thing was that one day he came up to me in the jail
and a notebook was a big thing and I was getting ready to get out and I didn't
even thought about it.
He came up to me and then he goes,
hey bro,
I got you a notebook.
And I go,
what's the notebook for your show when you get out?
You could write some jokes.
He goes,
every week you write jokes.
I never see the notebook.
And I looked at him and I go,
I don't even right and this motherfucker went nuts.
He goes,
you don't right and you go up there every week and do that.
when you get out here,
you,
it was like an angel.
It was like an angel.
I never seen the guy again.
I never heard from again.
He just goes,
what I watch you do?
You really need to write and get it together because you have a gift.
Just pursue this.
It was in the back of my head.
The prison really woke the animal.
I know so many people look at you.
I know so many people that in one point in their life were not good people.
There were there were fucked up to run a bad place,
but they turned around and became some of my favorite people.
You know,
you're a perfect example actually.
Absolutely can change rules and there's confusion.
People,
kids don't know what the fuck they want to do.
I was lost.
I thought that's what I wanted to do and once I did it,
I seen the reality of it and never did it again.
And for some people they take the lesson,
they run with it,
and for some other people they fucking keep doing what they were doing because
they don't really want to go anywhere.
And I'm really wanting go only way.
Even in my darkest moments,
I always just wanted a little bit of light so I could shut it.
Just to go forward with the,
I was looking for 50 hours just to get me started.
That's it.
To get an apartment,
to get a car tall.
I wanted I the Webinar fucked fuckers up there watching me that I got a break
and whatever,
and today I'm not fucking let them in or whatever,
but I'm alive.
When I wake up in the morning,
I'm alive dog.
I didn't tell on me alive at 49 he notify you kid.
I didn't want to be alive at 49 but now I want to be alive,
man.
It's beautiful because I crossed over.
I don't have that thing in the back of your mind.
Fine.
And that's not take her Marcy.
That looks Kinky to me too.
I don't think that's fair.
I don't give a fuck.
You're going to go to Mars now.
Now $14 billion with all the shit we got going on this fucking country.
Mars.
For what?
Who gives a fuck about Mars?
I'm sitting there going,
listen from gazing.
It's fucking tape.
They made this in Burbank.
Every everything that they do,
what's it like to go to the fucking place?
I ex what happened?
We got fucking age,
we've got diseases,
we got fat kids running around March.
A little by little,
we'll fucking dying here dog.
This country's fucking diet.
We got time.
I don't give a fuck what goes on in Mars.
I don't give a fuck what goes on in London either in 1529 I'm from the Church of
what's happening now and by the bucket,
you know,
10 years ago we hung out for years and you were talking about the moon landing
was fake.
Now you're all of a sudden you're happy about bucking Mars guy.
Come on,
give me a fucking break.
What I'm sensing
that goes out every day.
It's waste of thought.
We've got bigger things to fry.
Gas is $5 a tech.
We got this milk robbing guide.
Who's a fucking comic con I was fuck from Idaho or Utah or wherever the fuck is
from.
Against.
So Baba Jonathan,
that's going on good days.
His wife,
cause she's making fat.
Kids get fucking skinny.
That's it.
I mean,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
We don't even have a presence.
We don't,
we don't have somebody to vote for the next four years and we're worried about
fucking Mars.
Joe Rogan rarely about fucker.
What happened in England in 1529 we need to fucking know what's going to happen
the next three years.
You know what,
Doug,
you're right.
I'm about to have a baby and I'm fucking scared because what is he going to have
in 40 years?
What are we going to have?
We're going to be getting fucked in the ass by Arabs,
by bunch of white people
wore his money.
The fucking bottom line.
The square root of war guy is Didas.
I don't see any Didas and that's going to Mars.
Cassie sponsored by ear doctors all across America.
Sorry about that chocolate bar.
Fuck me up.
You know it's all right man.
I know what you're doing.
Just having fun.
No,
no,
no.
Watch the Olympics.
Fuck No.
The Dea is fuck the Di we.
Oh,
did you really say that?
Sick an anxiety.
You got to,
man,
that hurts him.
Brian's fucked up from all of God.
That's why we smoke medical by water.
I love the D and I loved the government.
Stay black,
stay black cops,
suckers.
I'll be
back.
I'll be back,
smoke weed every day.